Salut aujourd'hui nous sommes mercredi
C'est le jour de l'astuce de la semaine de l'astuce du mentaliste.
Je vais vous parler du VAKOG, ce qui va vous permettre de mieux communiquer,
d'être meilleur communiquant.
Quand vous parlez avec quelqu'un, en face à face.
Le VAKOG, faut savoir 2 choses dessus :
La 1ère chose, c'est que c'est pas un gros mot, on a le droit de dire "VAKOG".
La 2ème chose c'est que ca permet d'être en face sur le canal de son interlocuteur.
Un petit peu comme si vous étiez de la même tribu et que vous parliez avec les mêmes codes.
Vous connaissez forcément les codes de langage sociaux, les codes de langage générationnel.
Il existe aussi un code universel, on appelle ça le VAKOG, c'est le canal principal d'une personne.
VAKOG ca veut dire
Toutes les personnes quelles qu'elles soient naviguent sur ces 5 canaux de communication lorsqu'elles parlent avec quelqu'un.
Moi le premier, vous aussi,
les personnes que vous rencontrez dans votre vie : tout le monde.
Mais on a tous une préférence pour un canal principal :
en général on va plutôt le chercher dans le "VAK" : visuel, auditif ou kinésthésique,
et d'une manière encore PLUS générale, on va le chercher dans le visuel ou dans l'auditif.
C'est un savoir qui est très utile en PNL, en hypnose ; on l'utilise aussi dans d'autres choses comme dans le marketing, dans la vente.
Ce qu'il y a de vraiment formidable avec ça, c'est que ça permet de se connecter à l'autre en étant un peu sur la même longueur d'onde, sur la même fréquence.
Pour détecter le canal d'une personne, il va falloir l'écouter,
il va falloir l'écouter attentivement et il va falloir aussi regarder où vont un petit peu ses yeux.
D'ailleurs je ne reviens pas sur tout ce qui est mouvements oculaires,
pour ça vous pouvez regarder ma vidéo sur le mensonge où j'explique ça plus longuement.
En écoutant une personne parler, vous allez avoir plein d'indices sur quel est son canal principal.
Si la personne utilise des mots plutôt visuels comme regarder, voir, montrer ...
ou alors des caractéristiques visuels par exemple
aujourd'hui il fait très beau, moi j'ai envie de dire que c'est une journée très lumineuse.
Ça c'est vraiment une phrase de visuel.
Les visuels vont utiliser logiquement des expressions imagées,
des choses avec les formes, avec les couleurs,
avec les verbes qui sont en rapport avec le regard, avec les yeux, avec le fait de voir.
Un auditif va utiliser des verbes comme entendre, parler, crier ...
Des nuances aussi de son : fort, faible.
Et ça se retrouve également dans ses tics verbaux :
"Écoute, il fait beau, on pourrait sortir."
Dans cette phrase-là "écoute il fait beau, on pourrait sortir",
il y a assez peu d'indications sur le kinesthésique ou le visuel,
par contre ça commence par "écoute".
Alors qu'un visuel aurait peut-être dit "regarde".
Kinesthésique, c'est encore différent, c'est tout ce qui est ressenti,
qu'il soit émotionnel ou qu'il soit physique.
Il va donc utiliser des mots de sensations comme lourd, léger, sentir, ressentir...
Pour le temps qu'il fait, il parlerait plutôt du fait qu'il fait chaud aujourd'hui et que c'est agréable.
S'il a quelque chose qui le gêne chez quelqu'un, il va dire
"là il commence vraiment à me gratter en ce moment"
alors qu'un visuel va dire "tu vas voir comment je vais lui répondre",
alors qu'un auditif dirait "non mais t'endends comment y me parle ?".
Comme souvent dans ce que je vous explique, il y a des contradicteurs à cette théorie.
Ces contradicteurs nous expliquent qu'il n'y a pas de fondement à tout ce raisonnement là, à toute cette logique.
Pour ma part, je m'en sers beaucoup dans ma manière de communiquer avec l'autre.
Vous avez sûrement vécu ce moment ou vous assistez à deux personnes qui disent la même chose,
pas avec les mêmes mots, elles se comprennent pas et elles s'engueulent.
Alors que vous, vous êtes observateur et vous vous apercevez qu'elles disent la même chose.
Dans ces cas là, c'est juste qu'elle sont pas branchées du tout sur le même mode de communication.
Vous pouvez vous en servir sur des entretiens d'embauche,
à des examens oraux que vous avez à passer.
Il suffit en quelques mots un petit peu de discuter avec la personne en face de vous
de regarder aussi le regard, rappelez-vous la vidéo dont je vous ai parlée au début.
Détectez également votre canal principal.
Le mien, moi je suis un visuel, c'est clair et net.
D'ailleurs, dans c'est clair et net, y a encore une image.
Efforcez-vous comme ça de faire ce travail,
en plus ça va vous permettre de mieux écouter l'autre et de mieux communiquer.
Si vous connaissiez pas tout ça, je suis ravi de vous l'avoir fait découvrir.
Vous pouvez me le faire savoir en me laissant un petit pouce en l'air.
Si vous connaissiez déjà, ça vous fera une piqûre de rappel et ça aussi, vous pouvez me le faire savoir
mais là c'est différent, il faudrait plutôt laisser un
Pouce en l'air. Je le dit pas fort parce qu'apparemment je le criais trop !
Dimanche on a passé le premier tiers de mon défi de cette année
c'est-à-dire que dimanche on a fait la 122ème vidéo.
Aujourd'hui c'est la 125ème vidéo donc j'ai déjà fait un tiers de l'année.
Une vidéo par jour pendant un tiers de l'année.
C'est un peu ouf, c'est beaucoup grâce à vous : merci d'être là, merci beaucoup en fait.
D'ailleurs si vous n'êtes pas abonné, vous pouvez le faire en cliquant sur le petit logo qui est en haut.
Dans la vidéo numéro 100, j'annonçais le défi du prochain objectif, à 50000 abonnés,
je vous laisse regarder la vidéo numéro 100 si vous n'êtes pas au courant,
et merci beaucoup d'être là.
Le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog. Ciao !